good morning
the rules committee for thirty
may second twenty seventeen this
order please be advised
that audio video recording
of today's proceedings
being made this also being
televised a Mister secretary
please call the roll Cooley
Cunningham Carillo flora
Grayson Kamlager-Dove
Maienschein Mathis quirk Silva
Rama's here reverse Wicks
here we have a corpsman we
have a consent agenda answer
emotional because and gio
-- by ms work seconded by
Mister Grayson with a great
voice -- Mister sector please
call the roll Cooley hi
Cooley aye Cunningham Carillo
Carillo hi flora flora aye
aye Grayson Grayson high
Kamlager-Dove Maienschein
Mathis aye Mathis aye quirk
Silva drama Ramos I
request on reverse hi
Wicks I makes time passes
and this rules procedure